في القمه الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه لقاء يؤشر
على رغبه في انضمام اوكرانيا الى سفينه
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتاكيد من طرف مسؤول الاتحاد على ان
اوكرانيا ستكون عضوا فيه اود الاشاره الى
انه رغم الحرب قمنا بالوفاء باثنين وسبعين
في المئه من التزاماتنا بموجب اتفاقيه
الشراكه للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
هدفنا هو بدء المحادثات هذا العام بل اقول
هذا من واجبنا
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي ورئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه اعلن خلال زياره ان انضمام
اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد هو مساله وقت فقط
مستقبل اوكرانيا يوجد داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي الشعب الاوكراني اتخذ قرارا
واضحا بالحريه والديمقراطيه وسيكون هذا
داخل الاتحاد
اذا كانت هناك حاجه لدليل حي على ان روسيا
تعاني من اخفاق استراتيجيا واسع فهو ان
اوكرانيا ما زالت قائمه وتشق طريقها نحو
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو اننا نوجد هنا
[موسيقى]
خلال الزياره اعلن عن حزمه جديده من
المساعدات الماليه والانسانيه والعسكريه
بالمقابل التزم الرئيس الاوكراني بالعمل
اكثر على تجفيف منابع الفساد في البلاد
التي تعرف بانها احدى اكثر الدول
الاوروبيه فسادا بروكسل اعلنت ايضا عن
حزمه جديده من العقوبات في حق موسكو
موازاه مع الذكرى الاولى للحرب الاوكرانيه
واكد مسؤول الاتحاد ان كلفه العقوبات على
قطاع النفط والغاز الروسي تقدر ب 160
مليون يورو يوم